okay very irritated it's the case that's
reignited outrage over the treatment of
black people by law enforcement a tense
confrontation with a Texas State Trooper
leads to the arrest of 28 year-old
Sandra bland three days later she's
found dead in her cell and all of this
over a traffic violation many are
questioning if the arrest was legal and
even if it was legal was it all
justified Brian and Sania stopped bland
on July 10 supposedly for not signalling
a lane change he was about to issue her
a warning but in minutes the situation
escalated from bad to worse in response
to the uproar over Bland's arrest and
subsequent death authorities released
the dashcam footage of the altercation
but it only raises more questions
come on put out your cigarette please
come on
I'm in my car what I played nothing
there's a big difference between what
officers can request you to do and what
they can order you to do well they
cannot demand that you put out your
cigarette they can request it but you do
not have to oblige blende was well
within her rights to refuse well you can
step on I'm giving you a lawful order
he gave her a lawful order the Supreme
Court ruled in 1977 that an officer can
order you to get out of her car it's
meant to protect law enforcement safety
but wasn't Sania really fearing for his
safety here bland
didn't comply with this order so the
officer had the legal right to
physically remove her and arrest her but
others point out that he could have
de-escalated the situation rather than
provoked so is it legal for an officer
to use force while arresting someone and
Sania pulled out a Taser on the unarmed
bland well he never ended up using it
the question of whether he would have
been justified in doing so isn't so
cut-and-dry cops are allowed to use some
level of force with people who aren't
cooperating but it should be
proportional to the situation officer
insignia described bland as combative
and uncooperative she started yanking
away then kicked me both the alleged
kick and head slamming happened off
camera still regardless the situation
doesn't matter where it happened a DPS
safety with an obligation to exhibit
perfectionism and according throughout
the entire context that the state
prosecutor has ruled Sandra Bland's
death a suicide for many people her name
now joins the long list of black lives
lost as a result of interactions with
law enforcement
many are wondering would this situation
have played out the same if she wasn't
black and even though encinia may have
acted within the bounds of the law in
certain instances here we have to ask do
our laws give officers too much
discretion